why is queen g486 rookie 2 not winning  queen  this is so beautiful  this is very miserable  that'd be rough  yeah this is  lost  whoa  okay  so now after the queen a6 checks  now after queen a6  if rookie two quincy eight  black would win  yeah king ju2 is still okay  after the championship the intention no  probably not the intention who knows  yeah i mean it's it's it's unclear big  spot  a very very dramatic conclusion  in computer lingo king 2 was winning you  just end up winning this piece the king  runs away and after queen g4  it's a draw  if the king goes over here once again  according to computers but rookie two  the movie wanna play which looks winning  loses to quincy eight  threatening a discovered check after hg  rook f2  and that's where we are queen s6 check  is on the board  does very much look like carson's  intending to play rookie 2 here